our category this evening as original
score
I'm sorry sorry was it was original
score but it has has now been changed I
don't know if you possibly weren't
listening to the chat from the Academy
in the wings there but this category has
been slightly altered this year ladies
and gentlemen and it now goes let me get
this right
Best Original Score or performance by a
British actor in a fluffy romantic
comedy set in the South of England oh
honey you're better no no please I'm not
bitter not bitter I'm glad I'm I'm not
not not in the least bit I'm just
interested in the way it's done and and
and the nominees are Alan Silvestri for
Forrest Gump and let's Elliot Goldenthal
for interview with a vampire Hans Zimmer
for the Lion King Thomas Newman for
Little Women and Thomas Newman for the
Shawshank Redemption
and the Oscar goes to you better give me
that yeah and the Oscar goes hans zimmer
for the line
thank you I'd like to thank the
fluffiest actor in show business no um I
wrote a speech but I realized it's so
boring so I'm not going to do it I'd
like to thank my wife because she's my
best friend I'd like to thank my
daughter because she knows things I'm
cool because I did the Lion King I'd
like to thank the directors Rob Minkoff
Raja Alice I'd like to thank the nicest
producer in the business
Don harm I'm incredibly nervous I tell
you what writing scores much easier than
this thank you just let me go okay